it's been pouring four days in the
lowland rainforests of Costa Rica's or
so peninsula biologist Juan Carlos Cruz
is here looking for rare animal species
normally at this time of the day they're
very active a lot of animals were not
using before is that after a big crane
ditches to stop you know or during the
rain they stopped doing in moving soon a
poison dart frog flashes its bright
warning stripes it's a endemic species
it means that it only lives not just in
Costa Rica but in Costa Rica it only
lives here in the other peninsula and
another one with yellow markings nearby
we find frogs eggs monkeys like to eat
them so they are probably closed by 24
Cruz and his coworkers this is tangible
evidence that investing in conservation
pays off in order to protect land
sometimes we have to buy this area's way
also doing research is very expensive
having the highest technology for
monitoring this animal is also very
expensive having cameras having Raiders
having all these different technology is
quite expensive so we unfortunately need
the money to the conservation the
downpour can turn babbling brooks into
raging torrents and bring expeditions
through the forest to a soggy halt
we decided to return to camp
where Juan Carlos Cruz shows us photos
from the week before the scientists have
set up cameras with motion detectors
around the rainforest they caught
peccaries foraging and a Jaguar now that
the areas under protection the big cats
have regained a foothold we fly to the
capital San Jose Costa Rica has been
planting trees for decades about half
the country's once again covered with
rain forest but the government has to
keep searching for new sources of
funding total of the forest in the
country some government officials tell
us how they hope to convince private
investors to help finance their
conservation programs companies and
investors may not realize it but they
also have a vested interest in
protecting the environment well today at
the newspaper there is an article about
how national parks benefits the people
around the national parks so we see that
conservation is also a part of the
strategy for reduction of poverty and
now we are realizing that really
conservation and development are just
parts of the same equation it's
something that is very easy to say is
very hard to do it really in national
policies to get things moving in the
right direction Costa Rica signed on to
the International bio fin project it
brings finance experts politicians and
investors together to find ways to fund
long-term environmental protection
projects we take a look at one of the
showcase projects rancher Hugo Camacho
receives a few hundred euros each year
to plant new trees on a part of his
pasture land Costa Rica's bio fin
coordinator Guillermo zuniga regularly
brings visitors by to see the results a
que esto no se they almost relented in
munising this isn't really my main line
of business hi Maya I've got cattle and
timber be
and a small pension from the government
typically slow hey boy who is yen and
fathers without support from the project
he might have sold his trees off to a
sawmill long ago he tells us that
recently a buyer offered him a lot of
money for them but he's not allowed to
sell his timber that's the agreement
Guillermo zuniga knows that for a small
farmer like Camacho passing up an offer
to sell his timber is a real sacrifice
he tells Camacho they're trying to get
more funding to protect areas like this
Costa Rica needs private investors the
government says it takes over 470
million euros a year to compensate the
farmers that's almost one percent of the
country's GDP is not such a big effort
and we have to keep in mind that many
why hope at least that many of that
money much of that money will come out
of market financial instrument and where
people will realize that it is important
to best but they were University ought
they want money back I mean this isn't
it yeah that's it it's an investment yes
is it we of course for the local
wildlife the rare squirrel monkey for
example the investment pays off their
habitat on Costa Rica's author peninsula
has been preserved